robin
on
[Musique]
là vivent presque au jour le jour de la
disponibilité de carburants qui sont
préoccupations et l'homme libre nous
parce que des vieux bons boutons mais
système était en face aux nécessités
bonbons desserts sa régie pour une
guerre pendant trois mois au moins qu'à
résister mais alors que unia la titan
titan kaki capable dé doit mieux alors à
l'ehpad même ont été sans galons une
capable fait gros groupes électrogènes
you absolue
et
[Musique]
besoin de gonfler toilettes besoins de
nos comme si on me l'avait sol et cetera
et bien que je nous fais si nous font
lessive daigné de l'eau qui nous reste
et qui part tellement sale nous
conserver nous structurons côté nous
ferons une flèche dans les tabelles noxa
sont une colonne inferno et puis pour me
laver vaisseau ces mêmes blues sam
utilisés dans les airs voix mexique de
la briane l'arrivée soit belle et puis
les la rue a fait tomber nous bonne
quantité d'eau les passages nous mettez
claude adam et profanes contre manger à
vélo mais pour nos besoins nous acheter
le blues l'été bongo
2 le barrage au départ
niveau de godard ville
conseils de quoi effacer suivi du
week-end qui pratiquement prise en otage
par des hommes armés nouqué des
stratégies de générer social pour
montrer moniot que glo à son bien public
les phoques nous protège il bien qu'ils
comprennent nantes à mes guerriers dans
la majorité des cas qui exige équité
blue comprennent ça
[Musique]